[Music]
they're mainly made of eggs flour sugar
and cream cheese or almonds or chestnut
puree
sometimes with whipped strawberry cream
or pumpkin batter cupcakes B sells three
thousand cupcakes a day in 25 varieties
you see is a center for pastries but
this is still something special cheap at
Elias it's really cute and well made in
soo tastier the Austrian capital is
known for its cakes and other desserts
chocolate zakat otter and the diced
pancake dish called kaiserschmarrn are
classics in 2010 Renato kuba added
cupcakes to Vienna's desserts repertoire
at the time the miniature colorfully
decorated cakes were still largely
unknown in Austria but with ease this
mere hypothesis what we do differently
is to make them half and half we have
half cake which we call sponge and half
cream that's something completely new in
the pastry business because before we
either had really dry cakes with a thin
filling of gem between the layers or
thick creamy things like cream cakes but
this half-and-half is really new but
this is high high because this really
can move um cupcakes originated in the
United States and spread to Europe my
Britain Renata and Kluber discovered the
tiny sweet treats while on holiday in
London at the time she was working as a
graphic designer
raising two children and running an
advertising agency in Vienna
the colorful designs of cupcakes
fascinated her
[Music]
Mileva softly happy humor so my passion
has always been creating beautiful
things
my original profession was graphic
design with my career choice I decided I
wanted to make nice things in principle
I've remained true to my profession and
my passion I just changed the medium
instead of designing on paper I use
edible materials and those happen to be
cupcakes and torts in just four years
Renata Gruber has made a name for
herself with her cafes and bakery shops
in Vienna she's considered Austria's
first cupcake designer
[Music]
[Applause]
shortly after teaching herself how to
bake she wrote a book of cupcake recipes
roughly translated as a hundred and
thirty grams of loved it became the
German language standard for cupcakes
and sold out three times in 2012 its
first year
when Renato Gruber gives readings she
sometimes arrives in her cupcake mobile
she opened her third shop in 2013 in
Vienna's museum quarter this cupcake
restaurant serves warm cakes and savory
dishes as well
Renata's Facebook page
cupcakes bean has around 39 thousand
likes and her weekly baking courses are
booked out well in advance meanwhile
she's closed her advertising business
he's hit the mini my skip rocks I would
never have thought that in Vienna the
pastry capital anyone would be
interested in needing a new type of
sweet and therefore originally cupcakes
were just a hobby of mine other people
go riding or play golf and I thought I'd
have a little shop with a sales clerk or
two we'd bake in the morning and sell in
the afternoon that was the original plan
I think on the first day I opened up and
two hours later we were sold out and
it's kept on that way perhaps one day
Renato goobers cupcakes will rank
alongside Vienna's other famous desserts
when it comes to calories they're
already heavyweights
they didn't be enough calories when
people ask about calories we just answer
happiness has no calories hot Kanaka
living a latest cookbook isn't for
dieter's either it's all about making
sweet little cakes
[Music]